en las trincheras del frente con los
separatistas pro rusos el presidente
ucraniano cn skip elogió a sus tropas
mientras las tensiones florecen entre
los vecinos
gracias por proteger nuestra soberanía y
nuestra integridad territorial
al otro lado estás imágenes muestran la
reciente llegada de fuerzas rusas según
los servicios de inteligencia de eeuu
alrededor de 100.000 soldados rusos
están en la frontera y podrían invadir
la el próximo enero con el objetivo de
calmar la situación está prevista una
llamada entre vladimir putin y yo by the
washington amenazó con severas sanciones
económicas y con más tropas
estadounidenses sobre el terreno en
europa del este si moscú no da marcha
atrás
si rusia decide seguir adelante con
cualquier plan que haya desarrollado
para continuar su agresión militar o
para agredir militarmente a ucrania
nosotros y nuestros aliados estaríamos
preparados para actuar
por su parte rusia niega cualquier plan
de agresión
hay una cierta situación de crisis con
ucrania vemos una retórica agresiva
hostil procedente de las capitales
europeas y de washington el presidente
putin tiene una posición formulada con
absoluta claridad
hablo de las necesidades de empezar a
negociar sobre un sistema de garantías
putin de la estrecha relación de ucrania
con occidente como una amenaza para
rusia y ha advertido que la entrada de
kiev en la otan sería una línea roja la
otan tiene actualmente cuatro batallones
internacionales en estonia letonia
lituania y polonia destinados a repeler
un ataque ruso